on va revenir sur toutes les nouvelles
personnalités parce que c'est vraiment
le sujet en ce moment tout le monde
réagit que ce soit sur les réseaux que
ce soit à la télévision on ne parle bien
sûr que de la situation en Israël
certains ont exprimé leur peine après
l'attentat perpétré par le Hamas il y a
plus d'une semaine d'autres ont voulu
poster un message pour soutenir la
Palestine euh certaines réactions fait
polémique comme ce joueur de Nice qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui accusé d'apologie
du terrorisme on va vous raconter tout
ça euh d'abord il y a Philippe Lelouche
Philippe Lelouche qui était sur France 2
samedi soir euh dans l'émission euh
quelle époque c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelle il appelle il appelle je cite
ses potes musulmans et des féministes à
s'exprimer davantage regarde c'est quoi
ce silence c'estd que il y où ils sont
tous les artistes qui s qui s'émeuvent
d'un tout d'un rien qu'on entend parler
sur tous les sujets je pense à une star
en l'occurrence qui est un copain que je
que je citerai pas qui tout d'un coup
poste les légumes du jour hier matin
c'est où les drapeaux israéliens
pourquoi pourquoi il y en a pas c'est
les féministes où sont-elles on on
s'émeut et on fait des manifestations
pour un geste déplacé dans le métro et
là on voit des femmes éventrer et
personne ne réagit le manque de courage
de la société dans laquelle je me trouve
aujourd'hui qui est un courage de du
plus bas étage c'est c'est c'est le B à
bas du courage c'est juste de dire non
non non non je suis pas d'accord avec
les terroristes ça veut ça n'a rien à
voir avec je suis pas d'accord avec ce
qui se passe en Israël ouchin ça tout le
monde a le droit de pas être d'accord on
va y revenir je suppose on va y revenir
longement c'est vraiment ça c'est c'est
ça alors donc g Philippe Lelouche cétait
exprimer Gill oui moi je trouve que il a
raison de s'exprimer mais je trouve
qu'en ce moment c'est compliqué entre
guillemets d'inciter les autres ou
d'obliger les autres à sortir du silence
lorsqu'ils ne le veulent pas voilà alors
je suis peut-être minoritaire ici mais
je trouve que son son injonction à dire
à ses amis musulmans sortez du silence
mais c'est pas une in je crois je crois
que c'est pas une injonction ah si c'est
sortez du silence vous êtes tout mais
c'est un CR du cœur c'est un cri du cœur
c'est une profonde tristesse de se dire
à tous ceux qui d'habitude c'est prime
parce que c'est ça aussi c'est pas c'est
pas demander à des gens qui ne
s'expriment jamais de s'exprimer mais il
fait appel à tous ceux qui sont un peu
politiser ont tendance à à vouloir
émouvoir les gens autour d'une cause ce
qui est très bien mais là on a vécu
quelque chose de terrible et il se dit
on n pas nombreux à l'ouvrir
quoi non c'est c'est exactement ça en
fait celui qui ne tweete jamais sur la
politique sur ce qui se passe sur les
fait d'actualité jeen veut pas il tweet
jamais là on demande juste de condamner
un acte terroriste on demande pas de
savoir qui a raison qui a tort va pas
régler un problème qui qui est vieux de
50 ans nous en tweetant c'est pas nous
qui allons régler ce problème là les
gens qui vont régler ce problème ils
savent très bien comment le régler c'est
juste de dire c'est un acte terroriste
on condamne ou on condamne pas faut pas
tweeter toutes les 2 minutes et moi
c'est ce que je dis en fait demandez pas
aux gens de tweeter s'ils veulent pas
tweeter c'est ce que je disais à des
potes quand tu tweetes pas tu as déjà
tweeté on a déjà ta réponse on sait ce
que tu penses c'est pas la peine de
tweeter d'insister allez tweet Tweet
absolument s'il veut pas tweeter ne le
faites pas tweeter moi j'ai pr parti on
va voir on autre style il y a Marco
Mouli qui lui appelle les gens qui suiv
va appeler le le député Louis Boyard qui
selon lui veut faire du buz sur le
malheur des gens et gagner des voix il
balance son numéro de téléphone
personnel donc Marco Mouli sur les
réseaux et euh ouais alors voilà ben je
je sais pas vérifieré si c'était le bon
mais apparemment c'est c'est c'est le
bon apparemment c'est le bon c'est le
bon numéro voilà qu' l' a balancé sur
les réseaux enfin à mon avis c'était le
bon parce que là je pense que ça doit
être compliqué de joindre Louis Boyard
voilà Gill Verdez voilà donc c'est vrai
que voilà c'est c'est c'est moi moi je
l'ai pas j'ai pas essayé de l'appeler je
l'appelle très peu moi je trouve que
personnellement poster ça ça n'apporte
rien et pourquoi il y a beaucoup de
personnalités qui ne tweetent pas parce
que quoi que tu mettes aujourd'hui même
si c'est un simple message pour
condamner le terrorisme ce qui doit être
fait évidemment tu te retrouves dans la
sauce ça donne lieu à des messages
antisémites parfois islamophobe et il y
a des gens qui n'ont pas envie de se
mettre dans la sauce de se mettre
peut-être une partie de leur public à
dos parce qu'on voit que ça divise
énormément les gens donc moi je
comprends les personnalités qui n'ont
pas envie de s'engageroch on m'a dit
queun bébé palestinien c'était le même
prix qu'un bébé israélien est-ce que je
suis assez con pour pas pour croire
qu'un bébé palestinien ça pas le même
prix qu'un bébé israélien moi on m'a
reproché plein de trucs parce que j'ai
fait un tweet justement sur ça mais j'ai
fait un tweet sur un acte terroriste moi
c'est un acte terroriste que j'ai tweeté
moi je tweet pas sur l'Ukraine je tweete
pas sur ce qui les mecs ça les choque
pas qu'il a la guerre en héritrée
partout au Mali partout il tweetent
jamais rien sur ça mais quand c'est ça
il veulent qu'on prenne position on a
pas de camp il y a pas de camp c'est pas
on est dans le camp d'Israël ou on est
dans le camp de la Palestine il y a pas
de camp c'est une guerre et ce qui va se
passer ça va être encore plus terrible
et c'est des innocents qui vont payer
des deux camp c'est des innocents faut
arrêter de croire qu'il y a un camp là
on on parle juste d' batlan on parle de
terrasse de café on parle de gens qui
sont descendus en par en parapente pour
égorger des gens qui s'amusaient alors
après on viendra le temps de de ce qui
va se passer après on condamnera
peut-être ce qui va se passer après et
on condamnera sûrement ce qui va se
passer après mais là les gens qui
tweetent pas ne tweetez jamais alors je
veux pas que ça tweete après ça tweete
sur la mort de Naël à la défense
d'accord c'est un fait d'actualité tu as
le droit de tweeter ça tweet sur quand
on traite de raciste je suis d'accord
avec toi c'est inadmissible qu'on traite
de raciste donc on doit tweeter pour que
le racisme s'arrête mais ne prends pas
d'co ce qui t'intéresse c'est ça que
c'est ça que je veux moi c'est ça qui me
dérange ne tweet pas juste quand ça
t'intéresse tweet tout le temps non faut
tweeter tout le temps ne tweet pas juste
quand et quand tu choisis un camp ah par
contre là c'est un acte terroriste mais
j'en ai rien à mais non c'est ça
qui est dérangeant si les tweets on les
a les tweets des gens qui veulent pas
tweeter donc ne pas tweeter pour moi
c'est déjà tweeté je sais ce qu'il pense
alors il y avait avait un qui était
assez attendu c'est Karim Karim Benzema
qui n'avait pas posté de message sur X
depuis l'attentat terroriste du Hamas le
samedi 7 octobre et qui est sorti du
silence sur Twitter voici ce qu'il a
posté euh voilà toutes nos prières pour
les habitants de Gaza victimes une fois
de plus de ces bombardements injustes
qui n'est pas ni femme ni enfant ça a il
y a eu beaucoup de réactions derrière
Gill verdz notamment qui ne parle ni de
de l'acte terroriste qui s'est passé en
Israël et aussi du professeur puisqu'il
a quité après le drame du professeur on
en a parlé il y a un instant Dominique
Bernard haras et c'est vrai que ça ça
ça est-ce que ça vous est-ce que c'est
c'est pour vous c'est c'est c'est c'est
normal ça ou bien vous comprenez ou bien
vous moi je ne suis pas choqué je vais
vous dire pourquoi d'abord on n'est pas
dans la tête de Benzema mais Benzema il
tweite à l'instant on est dans la tête
de personne non mais je veux dire il non
mais pourquoi je dis ça c'est parce
queant il TW pas l'inanté on est le 15
octobre ça arriv quand laisse-moi finir
ma phrase oui d'accord mais
pas semain après non non non mais
justement Ron pas une semaine après lui
il tweete sur l'événement Gaza il tweete
pas sur l'avant alors on peut dire il
aurait dû tweeter sur l'avant mais lui
il se préoccupe et ça ça ça rejoint cy
ce que beaucoup de musulmans en ce
moment il faut le dire qu'il y a un vrai
sans doute problème dans la société
française il y a un vrai clivage je suis
d'accord avec non mais non mais qui t
pas pour le professeur tu t'en fous mais
c'est pas que je m'en fous c'est que lui
il tweete que sur Gaza c'est il peut
penser mais raconte mais il doit tweeter
sur je dis mais il doit tweeter si vous
voulez mais lui il tweet sur ce qu'il
ressent à ce comprends pas ce que tu dis
en fait Géraldine je comprends pas ce
que mais le problème effectivement c'est
que du coup euh c'est tu es d'accord que
c'est un tweet extrêmement politique
c'estàdire qu'en fait il tweet pas en
tant que citoyen français touché par par
un attentat terroriste qui a eu lieu en
France où il tweet pas par exemple pour
les victimes qui ont été qui ont été
trucidé en Israël et je parle même pas
des israélien je te parle des Français
qui ont été assassinés en Israël par par
par le donc ça veut dire que quelque
part son tweet par ce tweet politique en
fait il choisit son camp et donc lui qui
est un tel symbole et qui a une telle
importance en France pour des millions
et des millions de jeunes qui adorent
Karim Benzema qui se reconnaissent en
Karim Benzema qui rêvent d'être Karim
Benzema je pense que ce tweet là moi il
est problématique il est problématique
par c'est ça qui est triste c'est ce que
je disais il faut absolument choisir un
camp et là Karim il vient dire à des
gens regardez moi je suis dans ce camp
là il a très
bien de dit je suis pour la paix il a
mis une photo de Nelson Mella il dit
pour tout le monde pour tous les civils
pour tous ceux qui souffrent et ben là
moi je
trouve moi il y a un mec que j'adore
c'est Riad Marz
aussi c'est un mec exceptionnel aussi
voilà qui qui est pour la paix qui voilà
par d'utre footur par exemple oui voilà
oui r Oui oui je sais mais je connais
moi je comprends le tweet je trouve que
Karin Benzema c'est pas le journal de
20h il ne se doit pas de relater toute
l'activualité ou de s'mouvoir de toutes
les actualités il tweet selon sa
sensibilité et là malheureusement ce que
certains veulent lui faire dire c'est
qu'en priant pour les habitants de Gaza
il ne prie pas bah ou pour les habitants
d'Israël et qu'il ne prie pas pour le
professeur qui a été égorgé c'est pas ce
qu'il dit je suis désolé faut pas mettre
les gens dans la SA il y a des amalgames
qui sont terribles qui ont qui on sont
en train d'être fait en ce moment ce
matin il y avait Nadine Morano sur
Europe 1 il a Sonia Marou qui lui
demande alors un mot sur le professeur
qui était tué vendredi elle a tout de
suite parlé des femmes voilées dans la
rue aucun rapport on est en train de
faire un amalgame terrible entre
musulmans terroristes et cetera je pense
qu'il ne faut pas condamner les gens il
ne faut pas leur faire dire ce qu'ils
n'ont pas dit alors il il il a remis un
poste derrière Karim je l'ai pas compris
non le post que je vous ai envoyé tout à
l'heure merci une question de mentalité
j'ai pas compris il fait toujours des
trs très énigmatiques comme ça donc
c'est peutêre ça n' rien à voir avec
c'est très elliptique je pense que c'est
lié aux réponses qu'il a
justement c'est c'est pour ça que je
vous disais on n'est pas dans sa tête
c'est vous nêtes il dit vous n'êtes pas
dans ma tête c'est ce que je ressens et
et et moi je trouve que on lui
honnêtement je vous le dis on lui fait
un procès d'intention qui moi me paraît
beaucoup trop sévère je sais je sais que
beaucoup de gens ne sont pas d'accord
avec moi mais il tweet sur qui n'est pas
d'accord avec Gill et qui est d'accord
avec G juste d'accord pas d'accord non
je suis pas d'accord
après enfin je veux dire on l'a déjà dit
sur ce plateau le Hamas c'est pas le
peuple palestinien et oui on aimerait
tous qui est une solution à deux états
on aimerait tous que les deux peuples et
lui je pense que par ce tweet il veut
dire voilà souciez-vous aussi des
Palestiniens de gaz on me dit ce vousu
dire Karim en fait voilà merci Camil ça
veut dire qu'il n'a rien à de la
polémique et qu'il a le dot assez large
pour supporter en fait c'est c'est c'est
ce qu'on voit il tourne le dos en fait à
ce qu'on peut lui répondre en fait et
moi je trouve que c'est tellement
important c'est un sujet qui est
tellement sensible et Benzema c'est
quand même une personnalité une des
personnalités préférées des Français je
trouve que dans cette situation là aussi
sensible soitelle en ce moment il
devrait quand même peser un peu ses mots
je comprends hein il prennent le parti
et cetera des Palestiniens de Gaza et
cetera mais il devrait aussi dire un mot
voilà pour la paix plus généralisée des
deux camps au moins pour le professeur
alors si vraiment ça Luche la gueule ça
se fait dans ces circonstan là on va
dire il y a il y a pas longtemps vous
recevez Yassine Bellatar que j'embrasse
qui disait n'est pas engagé qu' soit le
problème c'est pas Karim Benzema c'est
pas Karim qui va résoudre le problème
israëlo-palestinien il a tweeté en son
âme et conscience ensuite vous pouvez
effectivement penser ce que vous voulez
moi la la chose qui me qui me je vous
écoute attentivement depuis tout à
l'heure et depuis même avec avec
l'assassinat de ce pauvre professeur il
y a pas longtemps dans cette émission
dont je fais parti et je te remercie
cyrilci je disais je disais que j'avais
peur pour mes enfants et vous mes vous
êtes vous mes tomber dessus pardon vous
mes tomber dessus en disant non mais tu
sais tu devrais remercier la France
enfin le pays où je suis né d'ailleurs
et visiblement ce qu'on est en train de
voir actuellement c'est ça c'est la
surenchère ce qu'on appelle une partie
de poker où tout le monde va riser à
chaque fois à disant bah tout le monde
attendait le tweet de Karim Benzema
parce que les footeux on les attendaient
à à revers et effectivement bah tout le
monde tombe sur Karim bon ben ok très
bien moi je pars du principe qu'à partir
du moment où il y a des victimes ou ici
moi j'ai condamné bien évidemment le
Hamas j'ai condamné aussi le le le
gouvernement de d'extrême droite de de
Netanyahou et vous savez quoi
bizarrement mais j'ai reçu des menaces
des deux côtés mais moi aussi mais oui
mais fa B non mais non je je te fais pas
une battle je te dis que juste
actuellement c'est que comme Gilles
Lelouche dit où sont mes copains musulm
Philippe leou par excusez-mo je je je
viendrais même pas à l'idée moi de dire
euh où sont mes copains juifs moi je
dirais où sont les Français tout
simplement et voilà donc ça m'emmerde un
peu à chaque fois de de mettre la il y a
pas il y a pas à défendre un camp plutôt
que l'autre je défends pas unamp on n'a
jamais voulu ici rentrer dans cette dans
ce débat là parce que effectivement nous
on est qui enfin je veux dire regard
d'un conflit depuis 70 ans et ce non
mais c'est important de le dire
c'estàdire que nous on se prend pas pour
tu vois voilà simplement dans un dans le
dans le premier flot et c'est ce que dit
le louche dans le premier flot d'émotion
que un que il y a peu de gens en France
des stars des gens qui représentent
beaucoup pour la jeunèse pour plein de
gens peu de gens qui s'expriment au nom
de la paix juste de la paix au nom de et
du terrorisme et Cera c'est des mots
simples ça c'est quelque chose que moi
je partage totalement la vie de lolouche
je l'ai dit ici je trouve ça un peu
choquant et même inquiétant parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a une telle ligne de
fracture et c'est ce que tu dis
guillaumeyz voyez ici c'est on on a un
petit sondage voyez ben Gill mundir
Guillaume qui d'autrre voilà on compris
voilà donc un moment voilà c'est un
débat aussici faut qu'on voilà chacun
chacun pense ce qu'il veut et voilà donc
à un moment voilà donc que en fait voilà
G a exprimé son son avis sur le tweet de
Karim derrière on a compris ce qu'il a
voulu dire mir aussi voilà jéraline
n'est pas d'accord je pense que Raymon
mais condamner condamner ce qui s'est
passé d'attentat qui s'est passé en
Israël ça veut pas dire qu'on en a rien
à des Palestiniens c'est ça qu'il
faut vous mettre dans le crâne quand on
voit des images qui arrivent moi sur mes
réseau voit des bébés dans les bras des
bébés palestiniens dans les bras qui
sont morts tu crois qu'on dit quoi tu
crois qu'on a pas envie de pleurer quand
on nous envoie ça sur les réseaux bien
sûr que j'ai envie de pleurer moi j'ai
mis un tweet pour condamner l'attentat
terroriste on m'envoie une série
d'images je sais pas de si elles sont
datées ou pas de bébés dans les bras de
de parents palestinien tu crois que j'ai
pas envie de chaler j'ai envie de Ch
aller je dis juste qu'il faut pas dire
aux jeunes tu dis que tu as pas peur
pour tes enfants moi je pense que quand
Karim quand Karim ne dit pas qui
condamne pas un Act terroriste et
derrière qui dit moi j'ai choisi mon
camp parce que c'est ce que j'entends
Mo je suis débile moi
j'entendsam pas terrorisme tu donnes la
force à PAL Mo je donne ai la force au
palestin mais je condamne
l'attentom pas parce qu'il fait silence
qu'il n'en parle pas que dans sa tête il
ne condamne pas mais là il parle que de
gaz excusez-moi vous lui faites un
proc par de G on a des couilles on
condamne pour de vrai ou condamne pas
pas dans sa tête mec c'est très grave ce
qui se passe moi j'ai grandi avec les
films d'Alexandre ARCAD j'ai grandi avec
du cinéma où o où les Juifs et les
Arabes il se tapaient dessus et qu'il se
réconcili à la fin moi je l'ai rêvé ce
monde là je l'ai rêvé j'en ai parlé avec
lui ce weekend je l'ai rêvé ce monde où
l'appel à l' arrivé on repart pour
combien d'années là 30 piges on repart
pour combien de temps avec ces conneries
là on repart pour combien de temps à un
moment donné régler le problème de états
pas de États mais on en a marre de voir
et des Israéliens qui sont tués et des
Palestiniens qui sont tués et en faisant
des tweets en choisissant chacun son
camp on va pas y arriver les mecs on va
pas y arriver l'union sacrée elle
arrivera jamais Simon Atlant et karimida
ça n'arrivera jamais moi j'ai moi je
suis triste parce qu'on repart pour 30
ans et quand je vois les insultes que je
reçois sale musulman de merère ton père
qui retourne dans sa tombe il serait pas
fier de toi ton père le Marocain à quel
moment à quel moment j'ai dit que je
voulais qu'un bébé palestinien Meur à
quel moment mais arrêtons juste d'être
con et réfléchissons que le problème on
va pas le régler ni là ni ailleurs c'est
50 ans 70 ans de problème mais si on
continue à faire des trucs comme ça
c'est les Arabes qui font non c'est les
Juifs non c'est les arabes on on en a
pour 30 ans encore et moi je suis triste
d'en avoir pour 30 ans j' envie que ça
s'arrête ces conneries j'ai grandi avec
ça moi j'ai 47 ans je me suis levé tous
les matins avec un conflit israélo
palestinien à tel point que je vais vous
faire une confidence quand il y a eu
l'attaque des attentats j'ai même pas
pris ça au sérieux j'ai dit encore un
truc là-bas avec Israël et la Palestine
j'ai même pas pris ça au sérieux c'est
après quand j'ai vu les mecs arrivver en
parapante j'ai dit ça c'est ça c'est un
batlan en fait c'est un batlan donc je
condamne et ensuite on verra ce qu'on
fera après mais faut le régler le
problème c'est bon les mecs c'est on on
a connu ça toute notre vie c'est c'est
la seule guerre que j'ai connu toute ma
vie moi j'ai pas connu une are guerre
plus longue hein donnez-moi une autre
guerre qui a duré 50 ans il y en a ou
pas il y en a ou pas là là moi j'ai pas
connu ça voilà j'ai pas connu ça non
faites ce que vous voulez divisez-vous
insultez-moi là ceux qui veulent
m'insulter encore sur les réseaux
insultez je m'enbranle c'est pas moi qui
vais régler le problème je suis
chauffeur livreur c'est si vous attendez
si un mec derrière sa télé se dit Ron
àou faut qu'il parle bah pose-toi des
questions sur ta vie parce qu' de 70 ans
c'est pas moi qui vais te le régler je
te le dis tout de suite s
moi pas merde cy il y a pas de il y a
pas de cy y a pas DEAMP on repart pour
30 en ferme il va y avoir des morts des
deux côté et les mecs te disent non faut
choisir il y a pas choisir en fait un
bébé c'est un bébé non mais c'est c'est
sûr non mais a très bien quand tu livre
Ron c'est ça qui me fait mal moi quand
je livre moi je vois des mecs qui me
disent qui me parlent tout le temps de
la Palestine je suis d'accord je vous je
suis d'accord avec vous il s'est passé
des trucs en Palestine l'histoire vous
allez sur Internet vous allez la voir
l'histoire c'est pas moi qui vais te la
donner l'histoire j'ai arrêté à l'école
à 14 ans je vais pas te donner
l'histoire maintenant est-ce que tu
condamnes les attentats non c'est pas la
question si c'est ma question après on
on règle les problèmes et j'espère qu'il
va se passer des choses mais moi je vois
des insultes même dans la rue et je vois
beaucoup de musulmans en colère à juste
titre ou pas à juste titre qui eux font
comme Karim choisissent un camp et c'est
fini c'est c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'on repart pour pour 30 ans parce que
c'est c'est c'est très dur ce qui se
passe c'est très très dur et aujourd'hui
si les gens ont peur ils ont raison
d'avoir peur parce que il y a des gens
qui essayent de diviser à qui ça profite
en fait et tu as beau lancer des des des
des appels au calme des appels à la paix
moi je suis ça me fait chier parce que
c'est 30 ans là je pense c'est très long
très très long non mais Raymon
aujourd'hui on peut pas nier quand même
que du point de vue des musulmans
aujourd'hui d'accord se prépare un
massacre sur Gaza et les musulmans de
France aujourd'hui ils se disent il y a
la légitime Rost israélienne légitime
vengeance même si tu veux et à un moment
les musulmans de France s je su d'accord
a il disent mais qu'on arrête de tuer de
massacrer toute la
population PL pour la Concorde il dit
les gens sont divisés PL pour la
réconciliation il
paséer raison de plider pour la
réconciliation en fait mais je dis moi
que c'est clivé aujourd'hui et qu'on ne
peut pas
ne peut pas empêcher les musulmans de
tweer comme ça 47 52 comprenez-vous la
réaction
de
Don y a une polémique aussi ce weekend
c'est ce joueur de l'c FAL qui a partagé
dans sa story insta une vidéo du
prédicateur palestinien
mahmoudanat qui appelé Dieu a envoyé un
jour noir sur les Ju
ça a fait énormément parler alors il
s'excusait derrière Yousef fatal j'ai
conscience que ma publication a choqué
plusieurs personnes qui n'était pas mon
intention et je m'en excuse je tiens à
clarifier mon point de vue sans aucune
ambiguïté je condamne fermement toute
forme de violence où que ce soit dans le
monde et je soutiens toutes les victimes
jamais je soutiendrai un message de
haine la paix est un idéal auquel je
crois fermement qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de ça vous g ça c'est indigne il
y a une enquête préliminaire pour
apologie du terrorisme qui est ouverte
j'espère qu'elle ira au bout les excuses
ne valent rien c'est absolument indigne
je ne vois pas comment il peut continuer
à jouer au football à Nice en France ou
ailleurs c'est pour moi scandaleux là on
est dans euh la propagation de la haine
voilà je scandalisé alors il y a il y a
il y a autre chose aussi qui a fait
beaucoup parler ce weekend c'est todibo
le joueur de l'équipe de France
jean-cler todibo vendredi soir pour le
match France Pays-Bas il a été vu en
train de rire pendant la minute de
silence qui était consacré au au au aux
victimes euh ça ce qu'on disait beaucoup
de monde et certains parlent d'un manque
de respect où disent que le joueur se
moque des victimes israéliennes
palestiniennes et de la mort du
professeur
Daras est-ce que là on tombe pas je
demande je je pose la question est-ce
qu'on tombe pas aussi maintenant dans
une psychosele pas pendant une minute de
silence est-ce que c'était vraiment
minute de j'ai pas vu leil pas vu le
match minut de
silence la rumeur c'est pendant la
minute de silence d'accord Mar il a fait
du sport moi j'ai fait du sport toi tu
fais du sport quand tu fait du
sport il s'est expliqué je ne pense pas
être un garçon irrespectueux j'ai eu un
rire nerveux mais en aucun cas je me
moquais de la situation actuelle le
contexte est assez particulier dans les
tribunes et on était au milieu de
supporters adverses certains ont fait
certaines blagues et j'ai eu un rire
nerveux je tenais à m'excuser auprès de
toutes les personnes que j'ai pu
offenser je je pense sincèrement là je
suis pas juge moi voilà mais je pense
qu'on peut lui laisser le bénéfice du
doute à jean-clard te dit bon va pas il
s'excuser derrière le gars c'est des les
mecs ils ont 22 ans 23
ans non non mais non non mais voilà on
peut là la vérité là je le dis alors
bien sûr Youssef Atal ça c'est
inadmissible
je préfère que les mecs qui tweetent
rien que tweet des conneries c'est fatal
là si vous êtes chez vous vous voulez
faire des trucs comme faites rien c'est
encore mieux excuseer derrière c'est
encore mais jean-cler odibo les gars là
franchement il a il a fait un message
qui est qu'on comprend tous après on va
pas lui tomber dessus je vois plein de
gens qui lui tombent dessus oh ça va le
mec il a il a il a quel âge il a 22
ansibo bien sûr qu'il est il est il est
il est touché comme tout le monde il l'a
dit d'ailleurs voilà il a mis il a
jamais été respectueux envers personne
et peut-être qu'il a eu un rè nerveux il
l'a expliqué pere un r nerveux mais 22
ans c'est pas oui oui mais non mais
ouais mais il faut que tu sois un peu
tolérant
aussi ou oui voilà non mais bon on va
pas tomber aussi sur tout le monde après
à un moment les gars voilà on va pas
tomber aussi sur tout le monde il y a
des mecs aussi ils sont dans leur truc
voilà il a un moment même pas qu'il est
filmé en plus ne lui fait pas dire ce
qu'il a pas dit parce que là on
sousentend encore qu'en faisant ça il
s'en fout du terrorisme il s'en fout des
attentat effectivement malvenu mais
c'est pas de sa faute c'est pas grave
voilà il s c'est mêmeexcuse
derrière c'est bien parce que vous
montrez la différence entre des
personnes qui ont des propos vraim
scandale et lui voilà il se retrouve
dans une sauce le pauvre arrêtez voilà
on va on va parler dans un instant d'un
autre mec qui est dans la sauce c'est
SADC